non ci sono solo risurrezione
il titolo completo è notoriamente un
ritardatario e ossessioni materiali e le
sole flash italy
io sono sin dalla più tenera infanzia un
cercatore di archivio e un cacciatore di
storie le due cose sono strettamente
legate ho passato all infanzia
adolescenza con la testa nei cassonetti
io ho trascorso momenti meravigliosi in
varie discariche italiane ed estere e vi
parlo di un ossessione o se sarà il
titolo del film del 43 kg visconti che
narra la torbida e casereccia storia
d'amore
si tratta di un libero adattamento del
postino suona sempre due volte tra clark
canale massimo girotti è una storia che
li porterà alla rovina è una storia
distruttiva che dimostra quanto sia
importante partire dalla da l'origine
della parola la sessione ha una radice
etimologica regata proprio la natura di
assedio al essere incapace di liberarsi
da un'idea fissa totalizzante che ci
cattura e che ci impedisce di agire e
vedere lucidamente è una parente stretta
di un'altra parola che appare più o meno
nello stesso periodo che mani ha la
mania è il tentativo di dare fornire
accettazione sociale a quella che non è
una pazzia furiosa ma al contrario una
sorta di dedizione totale e il
settecento e l'epoca delle mani dentro
quanto è diversa e la romania cioccolato
mania vulcano mania qui vedete alcune
immagini alle mie spalle dalla copertina
del bellissimo libro di softball canale
dedicato ad hamilton che è più grande
collezionista inglese l'arte antica e
soprattutto un instancabile
frequentatore dei vulcani sino ad altre
forme come anche quelle rovinose
l'ultimo a destra e romani e la passione
per le mongolfiere il più delle volte
esplodono rovinosamente
il tema
inizia ad essere trattato da i medici
che dicono ma insomma è giusto che di
queste passioni che rasentano la follia
si occupi la medicina medicina moderna
siamo a metà set
ci sono diversi titoli li vedete della
maniera la frenesia della rabbia
trattati in qualche modo legati alle
fibre sensibile all'ipersensibilità
la voce melancholia che in qualche modo
si rifà ad antecedente cinquecenteschi
sino poi a il famoso trattato di tissot
eroe digitale noto non tanto per questa
sua leggendaria trattato sui nervi
quanto piuttosto è il primo studioso
dell'onanismo titolo ovviamente che gli
ha garantito notorietà internazionale e
poi diventa ovviamente agr un inventore
propone questi rimedi qui trovate due
modelli di cintura di castità unisex tra
i primi
che lo hanno reso in qualche modo
celebre tra i numerosi cultori della
materia
questi trattati in qualche modo
dimostrano che lo stesso nella mania
hanno due elementi che li accomunano due
limiti la ricerca della perfezione e la
finitezza di completare una serie e in
qualche modo si tratta di aspirazione
che caratterizzano le vite le opere di
moltissimi scienziati moltissime
inventori moltissimi creativi dei quali
spesso si trascura questa dimensione si
pensa che l'evoluzione sia lineare sia
l'esito di processi razionali
trascurando quanto la dimensione
personale molto intima di ossessione sia
stata determinante per spiegare il loro
successo
e qui trovate esempi di ha citato
vulcano slargo e di susan sontag questo
è il famoso vulcano di terrell cui ha
dedicato 40 anni un opera di land art e
che consiste nella trasformazione di uno
spazio artistico di un vulcano spento
oppure
questo è un esempio di
immaginate una persona che dedica circa
20 anni della propria vita a cavare da
un blocco singolo d'avorio 21 sfere
concentriche che si muovono
perfettamente correndo ovviamente il
rischio di
fare quello che diceva un'affermazione
famosa di edison sui 2980 2998
fallimenti perimetro dalla soluzione è
in qualche modo la risposta che viene
data
il che vuol dire fa il paio anche con
esperimenti che era una tenacia
particolare avete visto che di recente
questo è l'esperimento iniziato nel 27
sulla viscosità della pace ci sono
succeduti tre docenti spesso sono morti
aspettando la caduta della terza a
goccia della quarta nel 2000 con la
caduta all'ultimo la wagon sia la rotta
non tutti gli esperimenti richiedono la
stessa tenacia
qui trovate alle spalle uno dei uno dei
miei eroi digitali bryan berg che vive
costruendo architetture di carta questa
è l'ultima sono 250.000 e lui in qualche
modo oggi propone repliche di
architetture cartacea evenemenziale
finissime leggerissime e campari questo
per molti innovatori creatori inventori
vale all'affermazione di una bellissima
installazione di stefan sagmeister qui
trovate il testo grafico obsession my
life better è quella che vedete è
l'installazione in scala sono 250 mila
monete da un centesimo
vedete la scala che sono state poste da
un gruppo di volontari coordinato da
stefano ci sono voluti giorni e giorni
in cui avete una delle bambine dopodichè
che è successo è passata una persona ha
sottratto un centesimo e la polizia per
preservare la paravia tirate su tutte le
a riconsegnate nel giro di 2 secondi
c'è rimasto male
il prova di fondo è che le ossessioni
creative come narra installazione di
saint master possono raggiungere livelli
patologici qui ne so qualcosa
e difatti
c'è una forma che è nota come
disposofobia che l'incapacità di
separarsi dalle cose di distruggerle è
l'altra faccia in qualche modo del
consumo compulsivo della sorte che ad
action e questa patologia è nota anche
come compal syfy collecting disorder qui
si torna la dimensione collezionistica
che in qualche modo riaffiora si tratta
di persone che
seguono due binari alcuni non riescono a
disfarsi di nulla e muore di fatti
letteralmente sopraffatti dalle loro
collezioni
cedimenti strutturali
assalti di migliaia di ratti ce ne sono
diversi è una forma volta diffusa altri
invece
non riescono ovviamente a buttare via
nulla nella loro esistenza ma fino a
quando poi solai terrifici crollano
stipano e ordinano maniacalmente tutto
ciò che possiedono
si tratta di pratiche molto simili a
quelle collezionisti che questa che
vedete non è una collezione lattina di
birra e uno semplicemente raccoglie
tutti i contenitori alluminio fino a
quando gli spazi sono saturi
la disposofobia
è nota anche come sindrome del faber dei
fratelli commerce due fratelli che
vivono ad harlem sono stati trovati
morti nel 47 sepolti nella loro casa in
cui furono rinvenuti circa 140
tonnellate di oggetti diversi tra cui in
25 mila libri circa 14.000 quotidiani 14
pianoforti
1500 palle da bowling varie ossa animali
uno scheletro umano che dovranno
qui vedete le immagini della folla tutto
sulla quinta nottata questo che vedete è
il buco in cui viveva omer era rimasto
cieco il fratello gli passava al cibo
attraverso questa specie di foro scavato
in una grotta di giornali i fratelli
koller sono diventati protagonisti di
alcuni bellissimi film
loro non lo sapevano già morti ma
avrebbero promette gradito l'attenzione
perché
hanno in qualche modo posto la questione
qui c'è lo scheletro si pensa alla fase
quello di onere in realtà non era suo
qui trovate gli ultimi questo è uno
chassis di una ford non si sa come sia
arrivato filippo aggiunto ha certo
perché c'è un punto di contatto tra
disposofobia collezionismo compulsive
biblio mania e qui in qualche modo
entriamo in medias res
molti mi gliori a un afflitti
disposofobia è una forma che spesso
coincide con la misoginia non ammette
altri affetti che non siano quelle
ovviamente per i libri per la carta e il
tema centrale mia riflessione qui di
vendita temporanea prova ad essere serio
e che in realtà noi dobbiamo la
sopravvivenza di corpi centrali e lo
scibile umano grazie alla presenza di
individui ossessionati che ovviamente in
vita non sa non sono mai stati
gratificati da alcuna forma di croce
mento pubblico ma che invece oggi
riconosciamo possano essere stati i
protagonisti di un fenomeno trasmissivo
delle informazioni decisivo
biblion in cui trovate il più famoso
bibliomane inglese phillips
sognava di possedere una copia di ogni
manoscritto esistente in europa e una di
ogni libro stampato a metà ottocento
è un illegittimo alcuno enorme fortuna
la spende fino ad arrivare al limite
l'interdizione quando la sua casa con
una casa di diverse migliaia di metri
quadrati non consente più il passaggio
fisico chiede alla moglie e alle figlie
di uscire forse per essere trovare una
casa più comoda loro accettano senza
patimenti apparenti
barbour forse molti lo conoscono per
altra ragione altro leggendario
bibliomane gli dobbiamo la biblioteca va
bene interdetto dalla famiglia la più
importante famiglia di banchieri ebraico
tedeschi europee del tempo quindi non è
una persona che ha un problema di di
cash per comprarsi libretti in ogni caso
grazie a questa sua passione ci troviamo
di fronte a quella che è la più bella
biblioteca di sui ratio mentale europea
ora per secoli gli archivi le
biblioteche sono stati luoghi in cui il
sapere veniva e the hills analizzato e
in qualche modo custodito
è un'invenzione italiana
le biblioteche gli archivi nascono di
fatti dai tesauri medievali si tratta di
istituzioni legate alle corti o
istituzioni ecclesiastiche qualche
trovate sotto la biblioteca vaticana che
è la prima in qualche modo biblioteca
europea ma la cosa importante sono gli
elementi che li caratterizzano cioè noi
oggi percepiamo le biblioteche come i
tempi del sapere i luoghi
dell'accessibilità pubblica e totale in
realtà non è così le biblioteche per
funzionare per stabilire cosa è
ufficiale e dunque cosa merita di essere
consegnato alla posterità di essere
tradotto alla memoria richiedono in
realtà degli accorgimenti sono cioè
luoghi chiusi fisicamente ben definiti
con le caratterische intimidenti che
tendono a dividere e eliminare
l'interazione tra gli umani il vincolo
del silenzio infatti non poter parlare
infatti non poter portare alcuni oggetti
dividono e soprattutto gerarchizzano c'è
stabiliscono cosa merita di essere
conservato e cosa no
da questo punto di vista qui trovate
alcune delle foto bellissime di candida
hofer sulle biblioteche ma trovate anche
alcuni archivi
io ho fatto l'archivista per quasi sei
anni è stato il momento più solitario è
felice della mia vita dopo le discariche
ma trovate in qualche modo un'immagine
che da un'idea di un'infilata
pochi hanno mai visto il ventre di un
archivio pochi credono sarebbe
bellissimo condividere questo sentimento
hanno visto il ventre di una biblioteca
sta di fatto che quasi tutte le
biblioteche sono difatti depositi velati
da questa sottile necrofilia
quella che vedete alle mie spalle
molti credo lo conoscano e bonnie wright
che il famoso cimitero di avere come
quello che è certo xvi è un cimitero
come anche caldo anche al più grande
cimitero del mondo e parlando di
cimiteri non posso non citare
l'immaginario cimitero degli elefanti di
tarzan perché lo dico perché nella
percezione comune gli archivi della
biblioteca sono luoghi polverosi tristi
silenziosi archivisti bibliotecari sono
le creature dalla pelle vizza dalle
lenti spesse dai denti gialli che in
qualche modo si muovono come il famoso
topo di biblioteca in realtà
le biblioteche gli archivi hanno sempre
costituito degli spazi separati
misteriosi in cui erano custoditi i
libri in qualche modo le fonti che non
potevano essere rivelate pubblicamente
la biblioteca di francia creò l'enfer
che era il luogo in venivano costruiti i
materiali in qualche modo che non
potevano essere resi disponibili a tutti
e la bri fissa a bari fece la stessa
cosa con the prize quello che vedete a
kearney che era il docente oxfordiano
che ruppe le palle per anni per poter
avere l'accesso
dedicò sei anni alla redazione del
catalogo è prova che quando chiese di
pubblicare gli venne proibito lo fece lo
stesso venne condannato dovette emigrare
negli stati uniti questo accade negli
anni 50 cioè la censura in qualche modo
tocca questi aspetti sin dagli esordi e
in qualche modo si stabiliscono delle
regioni e fisse che l'avvento digitale
ha rotto completamento e ha consentito
la resurrezione di centinaia di miliardi
di pagine e di milioni in qualche modo
di autori di storie di vicende le più
recente del peggior odòs quelle
apparentemente sconfitte dalla storia
perché se è vero che la storia scrive
vincitore in digitale in qualche modo ha
mutato
fondamente questo concetto e ci consente
finalmente di conoscere quelli che come
la storia ci ha consegnato come
comprimario figure del tutto negrete
cosa succede quelle che vedete sono
alcune immagini tratte perché è un
proprio si pensava che nell'emisfero
orientale diverse romeni che si
riparavano dal sole tropicale con un
solo piede che citavano anche come
ventaglio quello che vedete sono esempi
tratti a caso io potrei scrivere un
breve articolo come google books mi ha
cambiato la vita
questo è un trattato sull'allevamento
endres al dei ghetti
questa è la biografia del più famoso
uomo lupo cinquecentesca in realtà un
uomo cresciuto nelle canarie e poi
finito a parma
quelle che vedete sono testi sulla
storia dei giganti con gli uomini più
alti più bassi di francia e quelle che
vedete sono parte delle mie collezioni
di trash europeo perché si chiama trash
perché di solito era matera che finiva
letteralmente alla spazzatura
cioè noi ci dimentichiamo che per secoli
la cultura ufficiale ha stabilito cosa
poteva rimanere e cosa poteva essere
cosa poteva sopravvivere cosa doveva
essere distrutto tutti questi materiali
non li trovate le biblioteche perché
negli anni li hanno regolarmente buttati
questo è uno dei miei prediletti questo
crossover di generi con tarzan
movimenti da golpe borghese e un
improbabile uomo ragno con un ragno
disegnato a mano
si chiamava zimba avevo anche
un'edizione canadese questa invece è una
dei miei copertine preferite o 16 anni
faccio la rapinatrice ma ve lo dico
perchè fino ai proto manga degli anni 70
la cultura trash in qualche modo che ad
essere stata riconosciuta nella sua ha
in qualche modo dimostrato che le
barriere tra cultura alta bassa sono
state rotte vi posso confermare che fino
agli anni settanta era disdicevole
scrivere di fumetti fumetti hanno usati
dei prodotti per in qualche modo
sottosviluppati
e dunque non c'è la biblioteca che
ritenesse voi cercate qualunque
biblioteca italiana una collezione
integra di fumetti per ragazzi non parlo
di generi periferici non ritrovate
perché perché la cultura pop ma in
realtà parlano anche di culture
scientifiche delle liste trade erano
considerati meritevole di essere
consegnata ora google books ha
semplicemente scalfito ha digitalizzato
33 milioni sui 110 esistenti ma i libri
non dimentichiamolo rappresentano una
quota infinitesimale per dire in due
copie del corriere per correre alla sera
ci sono cioè l'equivalente della
quantità di carta di guerre pace quindi
se è vero che in sette anni sono stati
utilizzati 33 milioni 610 la quota che
rimane è ovviamente ben lungi da colmare
c'è un illusione nella digitalizzazione
ci vorranno secoli per farvi un esempio
in italia ci sono 5620 archivi e 13 mila
biblioteche escluse le scolastiche gli
archivi di stato custodiscono 1.300
chilometri di scaffali ci sono circa un
milione e 300 mila metri di documenti
che corrispondono circa 13 miliardi di
fogli fronte retro sono 26mila a 26
miliardi di pagine e stiamo parlando di
una cotta microscopica degli archivi di
stato
dunque per concludere il processo di
digitalizzazione appena iniziato ha
finalmente rotto il principio
dell'ufficialità e ha infranto una
gerarchia che è rimasta immutata per
secoli liberando generi personaggi e
storie che sono una formidabile storia
di ispirazione noi tendiamo a
dimenticarci quanto sia interessante
imparare dagli errori
osservare chi ha avuto un pensiero
laterale fino a pochi anni fa non era
possibile perché salvo rarissimi casi
non era possibile accedere a questo
patrimonio oggi invece la riscoperta che
appena iniziata ci consente finalmente
di
riprendere questo lavoro di scavo nel
passato noi siamo sempre protesa in
avanti ma ci dimentichiamo della
quantità di idee e di ispirazione che il
passato cipollari e con questo finiti gr